[Music]
my lab is called proteomic big data
we normally we talk about big
data you are saying yes for real
thinking about the text
a lot of web pages a lot of pictures
a lot of video and voice
music and so on and now we are saying
uh there's another type of big data
which is proteomic data which is the key
of life activity and the basis of our
life
and they are changing and they're
generating data and this data is the key
to diagnose disease and to treat
diseases yeah
i'm so happy about this
tiana and i'm very happy
because i came to
china in 2019 for about a month
and i
had some really fun
powerful times
with the both the people
like the hospitality and the love
but also with the professors and with
the institutions and what they were
pushing the edge on
and so i did partnership interviews with
picking university in beijing and also
westlake university in hangzhou
and this was
hugely inspired by also kirill
piatkevich who helped make it happen
who
i love you very much thank you thank you
it was a huge uh transformative life
thank you periods
and
it's a transformative life experience so
powerful
and
now um about
let's see
one
two years a little over two years let's
say later um
he real reached out again
because we pretty much laid the
foundations for unity we could say
like bringing the world closer together
bringing the world's
leading scientists and entrepreneurs and
leaders together in a greater harmony
and especially bridging together places
like the us with china or europe with
china africa asia just all together as
one more and more
and
so kirill reached out again and with
introducing me to tianan
who is a principal investigator at
westlake university he has two labs
there
and also he is the founder of westlake
omics which is using ai-powered big data
to
just try and understand what's happening
at this micro level and
increase our health and our and our
well-being so i'm really excited to to
spark this fire again with um with china
and with westlake university and welcome
to the show tiana
thank you thank you catalyst
it's a great honor to be here and
explain our research to to you
yes
and we were bonding for a bit uh before
we started the show and i was just more
um
gaining a
better understanding of what exactly is
um is happening there because it's a lot
easier when i'm there in person walking
around westlake university going to your
labs and actually seeing what's
happening
with the data and also with even all of
the trials and the tests that are
happening and the beautiful insights but
when we're remote it's a little bit
more difficult so
at least for now until we open up again
and we're able to see each other in
person but why don't you go ahead and
explain
to our audience
um
so what exactly is going on at westlake
university in your two labs and let's
start there and then we'll also bridge
that to
westlake omics as well
okay there's a great opportunity to
explain here about our research
in westlake university and the west lake
laboratory
basically we are studying proteins and
other molecules
which are gears of our life activities
and our body so if you look at your
finger
it looks very smooth
but if you have a
microscopy to look at your finger
after amplified for 200 times
you will see a lot of cells it's like an
egg
and these are so many cells there are
different cell reactions
but the cell is not the basic unit of
life if we have another technology to
further amplify a cell by tens of
thousands times now but let's say assume
that such a technology
then we can see an
another universe
in this universe
actually we have
billions of molecules
these molecules are mainly proteins
they're also nuclear acids
small molecules
and they are the building spaces of cell
and the cells it's very basis of our
human body and what we are studying is
the movement the dynamics of these
proteins
as the basis as the gear of life
activities
you can imagine is so challenging
because they are so tiny
you cannot see it you probably have
heard another
cool technology from google recently
they have a alpha fault
alpha photo version 2 which use ai to
predict
a structure of a protein of singular
protein so they develop
um very smart algorithm
you can
basically predict what a protein looks
like in
micro world it's just a single
it's a so exciting the entire world is
celebrating this major progress
but if you go to the context of a cell
and it contains a human body
this is the one protein out of billions
of proteins
so basically we are using uh some
cutting urge
technologies to study
those opinions of protein as a whole
so we call this type of science called
proteomics
you probably know genomics genomics is
the study of thousands of genes
and the proteomics is to study thousands
of proteins
you know there are billions of them but
we there's no technology to measure
every one of them we can only
measure thousands of them
in our time but
the technology is advancing very fast
then uh
you know in westlake university we are
collaborating with a lot of clinicians
from different fields some of them are
oncologists
and in the recent two years after you
left wesleyan university you you were
stuck staggered by
the kobe 19 and we also have some
research on cover 19.
we study why
the virus can
evade into
a human being
and why
invaded by infected by the same virus
while some people they
they just have nothing
they didn't even have a cough or fever
but some people have a cough and fever
and there are
long severe cases they have mild
symptoms but some of them actually
died from kobe 19. why is that because
they have different protein reaction to
the virus infection
and we have
almost two years of study of this we
also studying
why
some after vaccination some people have
a high level antibody
which can cure a
new virus infection but some of them
have a very low level of virus
some of them need another
second injection and some of them most
of us need the third injection and why
omnichrome they
are different from the original stream
so all these are related to proteomics
and also because of proteomics is so
challenging there are so many molecules
involved they are always constantly
changing so
we cannot do this by our calculator we
have to use the ai to
model the dynamics the changing and
predict the behavior
of the micro weld molecules
so this is all our
research happening
in westlake university
and also during the past two years we
got a new mechanism and also which
leading to my second lab in westlake
university
which we call the
eye marker lab
intelligent
biomarker discovery laboratory
and so this lab which belongs to what we
call the westlake
laboratory which is a provincial
laboratory uh interjean
province
and this
laboratory uh we focus not only on the
proteomics but also
other omics and with
this other technology we built up a
cutting edge facility
which
can support research not only in my lab
but also in other
laboratories in our campus
and outside our campus
so
this west lake laboratory
we try to establish a new mechanism
we are not only going
from zero to one but also uh hoping we
can go from one to hundred to thousands
and this was the laboratory served as a
bridge
between zero to one and from one to many
and this is a another
big experiment
originating in westlake university and
we are trying to
develop optimized protocol
for
translational research in
rapidly
revolving chinese
science
society
slightly different from
other places
you know there's no recipe
suitable for
every weld everything
but this is something i tried and
in addition to this two laboratory we
also now have a spinoff company
since 2020
in
june
so this also happened after you left
westlake university
and during the past one and a half year
we have finished two round rounds of
fundraising
for fundraising and we are now
have
about
80 people
in the westlake olmecs and wesley omix
is trying to
do from one to many
basically we are translating the
technologies
the biomarkers found
from our research
into clinical assets which can help to
improve
diagnosis
and improve
cancer
or
cancer treatment or treatment of other
diseases
and a major
[Music]
product we are developing
is to
diagnose thyroid nodules you know we
have a
thyroid just
in front of our throat and it's very
small organ but it's very important
it's a secret essential hormones that
maintains our
life
is also called ceo of the human body
we receive signals from the brain
and they transduce a signal and
controls
our liver our stomach our bones
and our muscle and our
also in motion so it's crucial
so cyril is also subject to
diseases
so
almost 50 percent of the adults
have a thyroid nodules
you can easily detect it
by
ultrasound you will see
at all age many people have a thyroid
nodules
but most of them are be lying you don't
have to
take additional actions except to
sleep more and be more relaxed
but
for
some of them they are malignant
for malignant you can also name it as
thyroid cancer
if you have the cancer then everyone is
nervous
but
there's a
great area it's about 30 percent
of the thyroid nodules
nobody can tell it is a cancer or lung
cancer
it's a
so man it's a it's a
great challenge and also great
pressure emotional pressure to both the
patients and also the productors
so my collaborator in singapore told me
so he's a senior surgery
so he said if he found such case he will
tell the patient
be relaxed
so your module probably
eighty percent chance will be be lying
you don't need to
do
more you don't need to do a surgery just
relax and adjust to your lifestyle
but if he's a junior saturday
so
he will be very nervous he will tell the
patient
okay now you have a siren nodules we
don't know whether it's malignant
probably 20 chance is a malignant
do you want to remove it
so
the patient talking to the younger
surgeon we're likely to
remove
his or her
thyroid but after removing the thyroid
he or she will have to
take artificial hormone for the rest of
his or her life
so it's so challenging so we have
developed a
protein and ai based test
which can
increase the precision to diagnose the
malignancy of the thyroid nodules and
this is what we are
trying to do
uh in westlake all means we are also
trying to develop
ai pharmaceutical technologies to
accelerate
improve the drug discovery because drugs
treating cancer treating diabetes and so
on they are the most important one of
the most important
industry in life science
so we are then there are so many
involving
protein measurements and this is what we
have business what's been doing uh
during the past two years
cool
nice
yeah there's so many good things there i
love how you called um proteins the
gears of life
i like a lot
yeah
that's a good one
um so there's
several
layers
we could say um
so at the level of of the encoding of
the double helix
is the
um
so that's the genomics
and then you have the transcriptomics
um
and then we have the proteomics
and then we have the metabolomics
and so then there's the omics for all
four of these
levels all the way up to the exposomics
the way that it expresses itself in the
in the environment
um and the basically like the
the feedback loop that the environment
has on the genetics itself so the
genetics are are in a feedback loop with
the environment
feeding into each other
and
okay cool so then we'll pro we'll
probably talk about that um and which uh
which layer of um
of omics your most you're most focused
on proteomics is that right
yes
cool
and then
another thing that you mentioned i
thought was great was that
if we find the biomarkers so we can use
laboratories
to find
biomarkers like for example the
thyroiditis issue
and
we can
if we identify
at the level of the proteomics the
biomarker
right the one that's showing there's a
malignancy that's developing right
yeah
and usually you can get that biomarker
is that can you get that without a
biopsy can you get that through like
saliva
blood
oh no we have to
get the biopsy and measure the proteins
okay you do you have to get a biopsy
itself interesting so then there is like
an invasive component to an extent of of
actually having to perform a surgery in
the first place
um
[Music]
okay
because then there's a level of
prediction even before that that we can
attend to even before needing to get a
biopsy if we can find biomarkers about
the malignancy developing even before
that that's that's even better
but
i see so then
yeah go ahead
yeah go ahead
it was a very important field because in
most cases i have to explain this
otherwise people may get confused like
you
so for cancer diagnosis there are two
aspects
so first is for early diagnosis
so the early diagnosis we needed
sensitivity
in a scientific term means if there is a
early
phase cancer we need to detect we cannot
miss it because if we miss it that then
you will and the cancer may grow too too
late before you can treat it
so for
early detection or we also we call the
screening
we need a
long invasive methods like in the case
of
thyroid cancer this method is already
there which is ultrasound
oh cool
you you have some
lubricant and then you can detect it you
will see a lot of uh thyroid nodules and
if we have a siren noise it's very
likely it will be
it's likely the cancer and if it's a
cancer isn't
really malignant and they have some
morphology and
the expert can tell directly from the
archer sound
but the next phase
is
differential diagnosis okay now you have
a tumor but this tumor can be believed
or can be malignant and this is crucial
if it's a
line i don't need to cut it out
if it's malignant we need to remove it
so in this case we need a differential
diagnosis for different analysis the
best way the good standard is to analyze
the tumor itself
and this has to be
invasive unfortunately because the next
step will be
surgery to cut it out
so for for many other cancers early
diagnosis is a major issue like a
pancreatic cancer
it's very you know our body so you can
you have to
you cannot easily take a balcony for
your pancreas so it's very important we
have developed a long invasive or based
on blood tests
to tell
whether it's a tumor or not but for
steroids
the screening is not an issue
it's so easy to carry ultrasound the
challenge the clinical needs
is to differentiate diagnosis
yes
nice
yeah so
the more that we can find it at the
stage of the ultrasound the better
basically because then it's um
as early as possible in the detection of
the malignancy forming
and that's that's our most ideal and
then i and then when you do have the
biomarkers let's say when you do get
into the later stages and you take a
biopsy you find the proper biomarker of
analysis i like how
you describe that as like a zero to one
right so you know peter thiel's famous
book
and so
you have a zero to one is like the
creation or the ideation or the
realization of something like that
where you find the biomarker and then if
you prove it empirically multiple times
across different areas different teams
let's say
then
you can do one-to-many so then you can
basically take the um realization that
was found and then begin applying that
across different hospitals around the
world for when they're uh in that late
stage malignancy to then find a good
method for um for transforming it back
to its uh non-pathogenic
state to its fully healed state as much
as possible so
thyroiditis is a pretty big one that's
is that uh like is that a million people
a year across the planet or how many
people
a year
there are
huge numbers i think many millions every
year yeah so side with
modules occurs to 50 percent of the
population
and for thyroid cancer is about five to
seven percent of the
[Music]
population
yeah
and then so okay so then there's the um
there's a general understanding let's
say um and then it's good because we did
a general understanding and then we also
gave a specific example um for the
thyroid and then let's do another um if
we kind of zoom back out again and then
we'll get to the
um the pharma discovery port part as
well which i find interesting um i think
when we zoom out again i like how you
describe that
when and this is a great way for also
for us to just get more excited about
life biology um because when you do this
like zooming in method um and you see i
like how you called it you zoom 200
times in and then you see a bunch of
little eggs
that are cells
i think that's yeah i think that's a
great way to put it and so you see these
little clusters of there's like 30
trillion just in the body
um
and
i like how that can act as an
inspirational tool for young people is
to say well what's happening at that
cellular level um
and how to live a healthier happier life
and also help others live happier
healthier lives
and i like how you also mentioned um
alpha fold also so like predicting what
proteins will look like that's such a
huge part of this so let's um
and also just the eye marker lab and
intelligent biomarker discovery and how
different proteins respond to antigens i
thought that was also
super interesting so let's talk about
um if we zoom back out at the macro
perspective and then we'll zoom back in
um
so
if we if we kind of
see
proteins as these gears of life
are you looking at a specific
um
like the specific um proteins that um
like have a greater effect on most
bodily functions
so is there a greater um
more let's say more generally produced
protein set by the genome that
influences a major a greater amount of
the bodily functions that is more
important for
um for you for your labs and company to
focus on
uh yeah this is
there are so many problems they are
nobody knows consonants really catalyst
proteins
you know
internal micro world universe in our
body and every protein has these
functions
not only one function but many functions
and it's different from
uh the gear in that every protein is
being synthesized and degraded
okay they are burst and then their diet
and the degree this is so interesting so
so the the protein um what's the life
cycle of the of the protein so it so
it's the let me see if i can get this
right it's the ribosome that uh creates
or assembles the the protein and then
how long does the how long does the
protein last uh in its sort of like in
its gear state right with the multiple
functionalities and then how how long
does it until it um
dissipates let's say a tough adjustment
yeah yeah this is very another very good
question we know very little about it
we even didn't know we even don't know
how many proteins are there and some
proteins they are they have a few hours
and maybe a few days and some other
maybe a few months and nobody knows
there are several technologies to study
this
and because this is very important in
like alzheimer's disease
is the because the degradation of the
protein or some protein have a arrow
have a bug and then it becomes
a severe disease for the human being for
the brain to function
we know so little about it
so uh you know we have a lot of
rules in mathematics in chemistry and in
physics
but there's very little rule in biology
because we even don't know how the
element of biology which is the protein
function how the how long they be
and where are they how they translocate
inside the cell
and how fast they move no idea because
we cannot
simply cannot measure it directly
and
currently we have to measure it
by some indirect way
but in terms of so
one second so the protein is also
proteins are also moving from parts of
the cell to other parts of the cell to
potentially do a different functionality
also
exactly so when your finger moves
actually it's the proteins are moving
and that's why your head can move your
finger can move
so so
so the proteins are enabling like the
muscular skeletal system
exactly they're acting the actins they
are there are a lot of acting and they
are moving so then the cells are moving
the muscles are moving and then your
your fingers are moving
okay yeah you were yeah you were gonna
say you were continuing to
to go on yeah yeah
it was amazing well uh we don't we have
a very little idea
so
we try to
indirectly measure the protein movement
the dynamic
so that we we have some idea about it
then go back to your question so which
protein are there is there protein that
we focus on so my answer is this depends
on the question the research question
so we we define let's say
the thyroid
diagnosis thyroid nausea diagnosis this
is a question
then we try to find out what's the
difference
between the belonging nodules and the
malignant modules
there will be hundreds of proteins that
are different
but if you know the key protein which
can be easily detected and easily used
to fit into a model
to
distinguish this
malignancy
that's the protein we want
and uh
if we're talking about a
treatment
let's say you know leukemia
it's very difficult to treat
but people found that
chronic myeloid leukemia
and
the others have a key protein which are
different which is this rubber protein
which is the fusion protein
after we've done by the
fusion protein we can develop a small
molecule drug
targeting interrupt the functioning of
this way called ankle protein
the protein causing cancer
then
the cml the chronic myeloid leukemia can
be
cured to 99
so
[Music]
that means for every
research question
every disease
every
there will be multiple proteins be
involved and our goal is to find out
what are the proteins for each of this
question
interesting so
so another one of them let's say
if we zoom if we zoom in for a bit um
is
you mentioned um the discovery process
for
things like treating diabetes
and so
do we zoom in and we look at
where
like for example um we can find
biomarkers at the proteomic level that
show us
where malignancies have developed in
diabetes and then
which
pharmaceuticals
and how to design those pharmaceuticals
to most optimally decrease those
malignancies at the protein level
okay diabetes is a very special case
totally
totally yeah
different types of diabetes there are
different cause and they are also
affected by the environment your
lifestyle and
your food and
exercise and so on it's not like cancer
cancer we call it malignancy malignant
means it's a cancer
just because of one cell becomes let's
say
initially the normal liver cell now it
becomes
liver cancer
they either proliferate from one to two
from two to four
but diabetes is a metabolic disease it's
a systematic disease very
very different but what you mean is
some
diabetes definitely
occurred through
the difference
or base function of some proteins
and by correcting the function of these
proteins we can
eliminate or even cure diabetes
this is a
very interesting direction and we have a
project it's not a cure diabetes but to
predict
that business we have monitored
about 2 000 individuals over more than
10 years
and every two or three years we collect
their
blood sample their stew sample and urine
sample
and we're going to
predict
now you are healthy but how about 10
years later
where you get a diabetes
where you get
hyper
hypertension and so on so we build a
protein based am model
also plus some of your
basic uh phenotype like your wheat you
with the
lungs and your
bmi and so on using these clinical
characteristics combined with protein we
can reach about
eighty percent of accuracy
to predict your chance
to get a diabetes in ten years time
okay so there's a data fusion of
different components for prediction of
diabetes and then potentially the
um the pharma discovery process for the
um the healing of those dysfunctional
proteomic components
exactly you know there are
now a lot of ai technologies
used in our world to do some prediction
you predict the
pandemic you predict
the traffic
and all this prediction is based on data
this data mostly from the macro wealth
you based on experience and sometimes
what we call intuition and we predict
something by intuition
but
in our research we're trying to predict
based on the
molecules in a micro weld
proteins and other
molecules
so this is entirely uh new
uh
new disciplines
new
well because in the past we have very
little idea
how these proteins they move what what
are their
change
in different physiological diseases so
now we have technologies to measure them
and we generate the
data
[Music]
and then we can apply ai so that's why
my lab is called proteomic big data
we normally we talk about big data you
are saying yes career thinking about the
text
a lot of web pages a lot of pictures
a lot of video and voice
music and so on and now we are saying uh
there's another type of big data which
is proteomic data which is the key of
life activity and the basis of our
life
and they are changing and they're
generating data and this data is the key
to diagnose disease and to treat
diseases yeah
yeah and even to
get insights into diseases even
developing um yeah before they become
um
cancerous or or deadly basically um so
that's that's key
yeah i love this so
let's see if we can um zoom out again
because i love how you described that um
the proteins are synthesized they
perform their functions then they
degrade
and then
they can live for hours or days or even
months
um i love how they're just moving from
part to part to of the cell
and potentially performing different
functionalities and just understanding
all of that is in itself so fascinating
so
there's
so there's the muscle cells and in
muscle cells specifically there are the
proteins that enable actins and myosins
for the musculoskeletal movement
that's so cool so so so muscle cells so
each cell group so from the stem cell
are all these different potentials for
cells and then inside of all of those
cells are different proteins
because
um
so so there so the the dna inside of all
of those different cells is encoded
slightly differently um with small small
small variations so that it can then
make
proteins for the specific functionality
of that cell type
can i make a correction here of course
yes 100
yeah let's say you took a muscle cell
and a white blood cell or red
or a tumor cell
the genome the gene actually is almost
the same so it stays the same but the
transcripted area is what's
yeah okay perfect yeah that means
isolation is yeah
yeah so so it's so it's like uh
it's like out of out of the all of the
base pairs there's like in in each
different cell you could say there's
like a little like flashlight on the
area that's doing you know that you're
only illuminating a specific portion of
the sequence for
um this functionality that's needed of
that cell and in a different area like
neuronal would be a different portion of
the um yeah exactly
and also protein your protein are being
synthesized at different speed different
frequencies are not degraded through
different mechanisms
and then the proteins which we can
detect
is the synthesized minus the degraded
and this degradation system also
controls
uh the protein expression independence
of the genes
so it's very important we want to really
understand how life works then you need
to measure proteins if you measure dna
you can hardly tell the difference
of the
muscle cell and the white blood cell and
the cancer cell
yeah
so there's also a
like
a cataloging
of
from the genomic level
which
regions
are being
transcribed
into
the creation of proteins in which cells
cell types
so there's like a big library of
um
end of all stages so there's the 10 year
old or 20 year old that has the very
healthy
transcribing and protein development and
no
pathologies that have developed
um
and then there's let's say the 40 or 50
year old that's beginning to get some
of the
earliest signs
and so there's this big library of data
of big data
and this ai powered analysis of that
data
to
to see like oh there's a little area in
this specific cell type
that is looking like
that there's a dysfunctionality at the
protein level that's starting and that's
going to cause a lot of other um
downstream bad health effects and so so
then from that let's say from that
library of let's say that you could have
um that we could have
um
then there's also the
like how to
solve the dysfunctionality
so it's not only when the
dysfunctionality arises but also the
solution to the dysfunctionality that
also defers for different like proteins
and different cell types and different
regions of the body etc
is that also how you see it something
like that
uh yeah um but i can see the
library that you mean uh probably means
some location in the genome
yes yeah you know this location maybe
for protein a as the product a may
become less functioning and you're
talking about okay now we locate it in
this location of the genome and then now
we can find some cure for
making protein a more healthy
this something actually i
respectfully wants to correct
yes
yeah yeah
because uh most people actually think
about life from the genome because of
the genomic origin
of the life
you start from
an egg and the sperm from your parents
and this doesn't genome
but you are individual after
20 30 40 years of growth and now you are
individual and this is directly composed
of mostly proteins what protein is
another world
because
your other well understood after the
protein is trans translated from rna
and the protein has a lot of other
additional genome-independent
modifications and dynamics
at this completely independent genome
because genome
we have
23 pairs
of chromosomes
and they're mostly sleeping in the
nucleus
our brain
cells
is said that they never or they tell
them
divine
you have these brain cells and they are
the genome never been
reactivated very opened they are
sleeping in the nucleus unless there's a
tumor
but then how can you
get a function of your brain by
analyzing the genome which is slipping
the nucleus is not the correct way to do
this
the character is to analyze the protein
which are the gears of the other actions
and let's say protein a
although it's from the same location of
the genome it can be in the nucleus of
the cell it can also be in the memory of
the cell
you can translocate in floating it can
also secrete out into the sub cell into
outside of the cell and go to the
circulation and take functions
and let's say if you want to make
protein a
more healthier
then we need to have a drug
what would the retreat moment
and these are actually actions through
binding to the protein a or proteins
related to protein a and so that it can
affect the function of this protein
and the protein banks also change
if you move
if you have a high temperature
if you are cold
all this can change the function of the
proteins
so
so actually we are trying to
tell the
community not only the scientific
community but also the
social community that
actually we should
study understand
treaty disease from the perspective of
protein
so we are now launching a big project we
called
proteomics to even precision medicine
some things
something like correcting
the
inherent
or the older way of thinking about the
diseases
you know the diseases are classified
according to like a double cho guideline
or other guidelines
based on
the patient symptoms
if you get a fever then this type of
disease
if you get uh
overweight it's another type of disease
and also based on pathology
pathology means
the morphology under microscopy
amplified by 200 times
and
more and more diseases are classified
based on the genome
like what you mentioned just now some
location of this genome
which is eventually translating to a
protein a
maybe is the cause of this disease and
based on that we we can predict the
disease progress
prognosis we can also decide which
treatment
used to treat this disease
but frequently people found
based on the symptoms
based on the pathology based on the
genome
changes
we still cannot precisely
predict the behavior of many diseases
and now because
you have not measured directly the
proteins
which are the
gears of disease and lying
so so but why why that because uh to
measure protein need a very
sophisticated technology
and the kind of occasional protein is
very challenging technically challenging
okay i love this topic i love this topic
so how do we yeah how do we actually
um
look at proteins because we have to go
even more than 200x zoom
and we have to
um find some way of like illuminating
them
um but still being able to like capture
the data
in them
and also how they function so how they
like express themselves
um
so and how do we how do we see that and
like do we do we have that at like a
molecular level and then how do we
like also see
the
um
how do we like color it to see the
different um yeah the coloration of it
all of that yeah to differentiate it
basically yeah yeah so uh
conventionally we use antibody to
measure each protein
so antibody means leave you now you know
you have a vaccination you need antibody
against
the dead
virus or the virus protein
and this antibody will
bind to the virus
of let's say
sasko2
not to another coronal virus but only
cyscops because this antibody has the
specificity
to bind to a protein
of the virus and this is the
affinity
uh binding and this immuno infinity this
is the basis of using antibody to
measure any protein they want to measure
so there's a lot of technologies like
what carroll is doing
is to
have antibody and they bind to a
particular protein and this protein
maybe in the brain
maybe in the tumor and we can use a
microscopy to give it a color a pseudo
color that you can see it you can see
this protein is a nucleus not a protein
membrane of the cell
but you know these are the limitations
every time you can measure only one
protein
and to measure one protein you need to
consume
one slide of the sample one piece of
sample
you know there are i already told you
there are millions of proteins
in each
cell
so
is it still the most common
is it still the most common for us to
um take in antibodies
um that then have um the
like the genetic
sequence for us to be able to
like when they bind to the target
proteins so then they have to go to the
target protein so they have to be coded
to go to the target proteins
um delivered there and then when they
bind the antibody to the target proteins
let's say
then is there like an optogenetic
component or something like that for us
to be able to have an illumination of
the protein to be able to read it is
that still one of the most common ways
or what's
yeah that's the most common way it has
been used for many thousands of years
people develop tens of thousands of
activities
to study almost every protein that they
known in a in a human body other animals
but they are due to these limitations
it's very difficult to
quantify it you know you can see it
but how much of it there's another
question what are they is first question
what and second question how many but to
to get how many you have to get how many
because
there are many proteins that are
expressed both in a biline and the
malignant
cells
the difference
is the amount of the protein
so to measure how many the best way
actually is using
mass spectrometry
and this is the core technology that we
are using here
so mass spectrometry you like uh for
example i can recognize you athletes by
seeing
by your nose face eye and ear and so on
but i can also
identify you by your weight
uh if i can measure your weight
with uh 20 decimals
or 30 decimals
so with mass spectrometry we can measure
molecules
with uh 0.0030
and plus one
kilogram yeah beside position at this
level then we can simply by measure the
weight we can get the identity of the
protein
and this is uh all is a theoretical
basis for
a mass spectrometry based protein
measurement and with a tiny amount of
tissue
which you can hardly see
we can measure tens of thousands of
proteins
and this cannot be achieved by any other
technologies right now
and with this technology then we can
actually
measure
many hundreds thousands of samples which
have been lying and with
another batch of samples which are
malignant
of different severity then we can use ai
to find out what are the different
proteins and
how much are they and find the
biomarkers and build am models to
distinguish them
so building ai models to distinguish at
the level of 30 decimal places using
mass spectrometer spectrography um
so spectrometry
um
so
so then um
so the different molecular weights
basically will tell you um which
molecules are present
and yeah and then
and then how much of them also in the
protein and then if so then if there's
like a 17 year old let's say
um they're supposed to be like a normal
level of
all molecules present in the protein but
if there's a 45 year old that is
beginning to have one amount of
molecules higher than the other that
could be an indicator for pathology
dysfunction
yeah yeah we also have a prototype aging
we measure the
proteins in different organs
along the lifetime of a mouse
and then we can see differences
how
different organs getting old and when
they get old will liver get old what are
the proteins which are changed
we are
stomach getting old we are brain getting
out what are the differences
that's so cool and then so then um
so i love that so the stomach the brain
the muscles just the different areas
when they get old in this library you
could say is the data
that shows that um
in those different regions
there's usually this
a molecule will get too much of in the
protein or whatnot and so there's
there'll be like a pattern analysis that
we'll have in this library
um to predict dysfunctionality
so would you say that when we
when we predict um the dysfunctionality
let's say um
i have my uh levels um you have your
levels um there's young kid levels
there's older people levels and they're
all interestingly different um even in
the same let's say area of um the
stomach cell and that the stomach cell
has a specific um composition of of
molecules that is supposed to be there
at a healthy state
and then
when there's a um a dysfunctionality in
the at the at the level of molecules
again it's so cool so mass spectrometry
will tell us that there's that
that there's that dysfunctionality
developing
and then so then what would be your
solution then so is this where the
the ai
big pharma component comes in to to do
this like testing on
those regions that kind of thing to see
if it can
bring it back to homeostasis or what or
what
yeah so you know
disease
or aging actually evolves from the
molecular basis
basically the protein level
and to the cellular basis
so that which means
when you're getting a old
your protein change first
and then you will at that time you don't
see any other difference by looking at
your face
you don't see any difference by looking
at your finger
after under microscopy the cell they're
the same but the protein is getting old
but
after a certain threshold after reaching
some threshold you begin to see the
difference at a cell level
and after a certain
time then you start to see
from
the micro
level your face or
your hair becomes seems different
so if we have the ability
to
if we have a glass
okay we can see
if a camera can see you from the other
end of the world but if we
have the proteomic technology
we can see
changes so some time changes
which will precede
the macro field change
and this is the other basis for us to
[Music]
manage diseases for example if we're
cancer patients
they
they are already diagnosed with the
cancer
and we want to know whether which drug
should be used to treat this cancer
the ordinary practice is treated with
drug a because drug a is effective in 80
percent of people patients like he
like this patient
let me treat it
after three months we do a ct
or six months do a ct to see whether
tumors shrink
initially so big no shrink even shrink
okay successful we should continue to
use this drug
if it doesn't shrink or even grow okay
we waste three
months so the idea is if we have a
cutting-edge proteome technology an air
model
then we can maybe tell
at one week or two weeks
before the tumor swing will grow we
already can see protein level change
because every drug
they're actioning through some proteins
or
multiple proteins
and the
key
is we don't know which protein it will
the drug will bind to
because they will we know some of them
we know maybe every drug developed
uh have some what we call moa
mode of action we know something about
it
but we don't know everything we don't
know
how much change
this drug will induce to affect the
protein and this is what we are doing
and this change can be quantitative
change
can be used to build a a model and this
model
can
predict whether drink demands
and this is a
basic principle of a heart vision this
will work in clinic and this is also
what we are trying to do uh with a
few clinical trials
uh with ovarian cancer
with a
triple negative breast cancer
and thyroid cancer and so on
interesting so in the later stages um
like you're describing now
is the
like
is developing as as best of a
pharmaceutical remedy as possible
deploying that and then analyzing the
cancer and seeing if it's decreased
so that's later stage
and then earlier stage
is um potentially
the
like as best as we can creating like
computer simulations of the
of what it would look like to um
to bring in some sort of like you know
everyone's been you know feeling the
whole thing of like what can i actually
like take
that can like boost the biology of my
vehicle like what like what could
actually boost like the entirety of it
not only cognitively metabolically etc
all of it um
and
so
um is there something that we could be
in a sense um even before it gets to
cancer or tumor or malignancy could we
go even like running these simulations
let's say where
even at the beginning level of like a
molecular
increase
or decrease
from the normal let's say from what it's
supposed to be that then we could
have in that simulation is this
pharmaceutical or is this specific um
remedy that we're applying is it
actually able to bring us back to
homeostasis to like to full health or
even better than that um
and so i i love that and that that's
also that's also really exciting and it
feels like
um
it feels like it feels like anticipating
um
the future
more than
um waiting until the later stages of
the disease kick in like basically
tackling
aging at the level of like you said pro
protein dysfunctionality
um before it even hap like really as
it's starting basically as it imbalances
yeah yeah yeah yeah so the human being
is a huge machine
composed of trillions of cells and each
cell has a
countless proteins
if we can measure the protein we know
the secret of how the machine runs and
we can predict the microwave behavior of
this huge machine
yes
but this is not easy so this is our
vision
we still need to accumulate sufficient
data big data before we can have a
reliable ai model to predict such a
sophisticated system
so you know
we have
more than
seven
billion
individuals in the
earth on earth and we are more than
eight now
eight now okay
but still a small number compared to the
proteins in one single cell
you think so are there more than eight
billion proteins in a single cell
sure yeah
really i heard last time that it was
like
thousands of different proteins um but
so so there could be like you you're
saying there could be like millions of
each one of those thousands or something
like that um yeah there are a little
huge number
i didn't know that we were talking over
billions in each cell
billions of proteins yeah
[Music]
it's estimated
nobody knows how many but you know there
are millions type of proteins and for
each protein there are
multiple copies
yeah interesting so millions of millions
of types and then um there are multiple
copies cool that's crazy
in each cell
that you should say
god that's nuts
um okay so i have a couple more
questions
um
so one of them is um
do you want to share anything else about
um the way that like westlake um is
like
um
about your lab that has uh about i think
you said 30 or so um people right now or
also about um west lake omix and how it
has like 80 or so people right now and
how you're providing these um
conventional applications uh translating
the scientific um insights do you want
to talk about anything else about that
funnel or that process or about how
you're like recruiting for it or
creating like international
relationships for it um do you want to
share anything else about that
yeah it's a very good question actually
we are collaborating a lot with
international
collaborators we have actually very
nice facility and also exciting with
such topics we hope more people could
join us in either in
wesleyan university westlake laboratory
also
the westlake olmecs for this exciting
research and application
so
i'm also
the general secretary of chinese
society for human
organization and
we are
gathering
a bunch of
exciting passionate young scientists
their graduate students their posters
they are willing to
communicate with
other colleagues peers
outside china
and we are initiating a big science
product
with
professor fusuhur in
beijing which is funded by
most minister of science and technology
in china we are really hoping to
collaborate with the
clinicians
healthcare practitioners and ai
scientists
all over the world to move forward as
this exciting proteomic big data
research you know
this cannot be achieved by a single
group by a single country and the
benefit will not only be
belong to the hanzo or china is
for the sikh of
the entire human being
after we solve any disease like a
thyroid cancer or leukemia or ovarian
cancer should be helpful for anyone in
the world
however
there are indeed a lot of challenges
you know
most people they understand
genomics
and very few people really knows
what what is a protein
how many proteins are there and how soft
basically they are there how dynamic are
there
and how to measure them and how to how
can we use that for
disease diagnosis and therapeutics and
these are all open questions and
we need education
to
so that more people can understand and
this is particularly important for
application of this technology in a
clinic because you know
clinic uh
diagnosis is not something like an
iphone you invent an iphone and you can
sell in the markets
so we develop a bio technology with
developer drive we need to get a proof
from the authorities like
fda the u.s
or
chinese npa and so on
and we need to
let them understand
uh what's the gears of life and what's
the basic molecular basis of the
therapeutics
and this will need some time it will not
take a long time but you know we still
need
some explanation why
why protein
is the molecule that we should measure
and the
ai is also some people have concern
so ai
most people think okay it's powerful but
it looks like a black box what's inside
the ai can explain to me uh
how do you use this protein and then you
get a score i've got a risk score for
but this you know this need a different
logic
and many people think mutation of a gene
is the cause of a pro of a disease
then if you measure protein what what
mutation is corresponding to
and you know uh for this type of
question
and we have to tell them okay just like
what i did to you
during the past
one hour
the protein have a different logic
proteins are
many countries that are changing they
have been suicide and they've been
degraded
and all this we need
help from you and many other
colleagues
from different fields
first
you should
maybe understand
this science
and understand
now we can do a lot of uh cool
protein measurements
so i started to protein
research
more than 10 years ago studying
singapore at that time
the protein measurement is
very expensive
much much more expensive than what we
have now and also not very precise so
now everything changed
but
many people they are still some of the
scientists who has
done proteomics in the past they have
just the older impressions okay
proteomics
expensive and
not very precise and
they didn't know noise changing so we
are talking a lot to
uh scientists in china
uh we have been interviewed for by many
times to explain this after
normally after one hour
or so
they will
understand now he's different it's a
different
field and there are a lot of cool
technologies but
to the
international community
we also need such a
education so i'm also involved in uh
hewpow which is the international con
organization for human proteome and they
are scientific peers from different
countries
if you look at
20 about 20 years ago
proteomics get a lot of support from
academia from
industrial
and
they are having very good research
outcome and they are have a high
expectation from many fields
saying that proteome is going to change
the world
but
you know during the past 15 years
there are a lot of frustrations
because of the immature technology and
over claims and so on
so
in many countries actually
people are not very supportive of
proteomic research so this makes very uh
uh many of our peers the other countries
are relatively tough
but recently you probably heard
uh
president joe biden he
re-launched the cancer moonshot
project on the 2nd of february
and one major
[Music]
project in this initiative
is called the cp tech
the clinical proteomics analysis of
cancer tissue consulting and
this project actually
uh is many proteomics and the director
henry rodgers is also our
long-term uh collaborators when i was in
zurich
and sydney actually we joined cancer
moonshots
via
switzerland uk and
australia
so this uh and biden president biden
also joined our pupil meeting i think
2019
i don't know sorry it's 2016
[Music]
or so so his spoke
in the
proteome
uh meeting annual meeting
and also how the great promise for the
field
so
with your
kind interview i hope to
also advocate
the
maybe more understanding
of the
proteomics field which has changed
dramatically during the past couple of
years
and now we really have a practical
technology to use for clinic
and we have a lot of companies
like our company wesley omix are
equipped with cutting-edge proteomic
technology and ai models which can
provide
practical
assets to
treat some diseases such as
thyroid nodule diagnosis
so we also
[Music]
hope to
extend our
uh so before this test can be a proven
clinic as a ibd
in virtual diagnosis
tools it will have ldt lab development
technology ltt so we hope also
to
test our ldt
as a research phase in
different places in china and also maybe
oversea
i have friends in california in stanford
and we are talking to them because they
have a quite mature
industry for ldt so
in contrast china is just starting to
develop ldt so regulation is not
really mature so hopefully through
the collaboration scientific
collaboration between different
countries
uh china and the u.s they are not
competitors but they are actually we can
our scientists can work together to
promote uh the
uh
the the healthcare like a presidential
biden said he wants cancer
uh mortality decreased by
fifty percent or twenty five percent in
twenty in twenty five years with fifty
percent by 25 years
so
no country can do this by by
their own and the benefit will benefit
the entire human being not only
united states but also europe and china
so i hope through the
collaboration between uh scientists
after so technology i have so many
collaborations in the states
and i really hope you can when they
come to here and see what we are doing
and uh
also
have some our voice heard by
not only
the people in our field but also by the
ordinary people by the patients
to
have them
aware of these new technologies
yes
yeah beautiful
um
and i feel like that's one of the main
goals is to
make it so that we don't have um data
silos around the planet
but rather that there's data
interoperability across labs and across
um institutions
and then that we can leverage that data
interoperability
to be
even more like a single unified
planetary force
and
um do things like decrease the amount of
people dying by cancer because we've inc
because we've increased our data
interoperability
um very similar with like cellular
communication as well so you know yeah
on the micro levels the same thing on
the macro level um as above so below
and
um and the other thing that you
mentioned that i really respect a lot is
the patients right so the people and the
the average like population who would
love to
um hear and learn more about this
because it's going to be so applicable
when
let's say they have a family member
going through a disease of some sort for
them to know oh hey i remember that
there's actually these important labs
doing this work and maybe i can
get involved in what they're doing so
that my family member can live longer so
they can be healed or whatnot whatever
it is so
i love that also um
so yeah hugely excited about the um the
international uh collaborations and data
interoperability and success moving
forward as a unified planet as well as
getting this out to the masses via even
content like this and and beyond just
making it more and more
um friendly and simple for us to
understand about the advances that are
happening and how they can be applicable
for our lives exactly so we're going to
host a meeting
in collaboration with new england
general medicine
and also cancer hospital in china
we are focusing on
molecular diagnosis of thyroid cancers
and we have invited all the opinion
leaders in china and also in the united
states in harvard in montmartre and snow
catering and also people from california
a
professor in japan who is a
major contributor to the whole guideline
for thyroid nodule diagnosis
so we will meet together some of them
virtually because of the pandemic
hopefully next year we can gather
physically so we're going to talk about
countless status of ceremonial diagnosis
and what are the existing technology
what are the limitations
if any and what are the emerging
technologies
to
have a better management of this disease
and we're also trying to interview some
of the patients there are so many
patients uh in china
and if you actually if you're interested
probably can
join our events and uh
do something
some interview some people in the states
or in
i believe a lot of people will have
salary nodules we just ask them what
they think about about it have they cut
it uh uh have uh have do they have
concern about it and what are their
concerns and we're also trying to make
some cartoon
in both chinese english to explain the
what's the thyroid and what's the
biology and what are the disease of this
thyroid
organ and i think that would be very
very interesting every year there are
millions of people have their thyroid
cut out removed and after remove removal
they found that actually didn't have to
this is simply because there's no
precise diagnosis method
yeah and this sounds great this sounds
like a
an awesome upcoming event in march for
for doing exactly what we just said
bringing us closer together creating
more interoperability um between data um
healing more people around the world so
that's great and i do feel like there's
going to be a lot more
um
opportunities for us to to collaborate
and create together and just to you know
respark our relationship uh with west
lake as well as um china at large and
um it's exciting for me to bring a
greater sense of unity together and
meeting basic needs and actualizing
everyone's full potential and
um it just you know that's what drives
my heart and that's what drives our
heart um that's why we do
what we do
so
thanks so much for coming on the show
tian then thank you brother
oh thanks so much for your time
i really glad to talking to you haven't
talking to uh
following friends for a long time
such a casual way yeah he actually
invited me to talk a lot more than what
i have thought about
nice yeah that's always also
exciting is when
you feel like we had a good conversation
for your further ideas and creativity
that's always very very important yeah
yeah you have a very nice summary every
time when i uh talk about something and
this uh
inspired me to talk about more
yeah
that's great and and also the nuances
where you like helped correct uh and
make it more clear that we that i was
actually um knowledgeable about the the
central dogma of biology so just i
appreciated your corrections also great
those were very important um thank you
yeah that's my job do you have any
website of your company that i can
learn more about what they are doing
yeah of course yeah so one of the main
ones
that i'll send you is the uh no limits
society so that's the main thing that
we're building and then of course
simulation which is the show the show
that i host
um
so yeah so i'll send you those links of
course and i'll have them in the bio as
well i'll also put um
the links to
the google mix
dot com as well as the westlake omics
dot com links in the bio for people to
check out and and also if you guys would
like to you can leave us a comment below
with your thoughts on the episode we
would love to hear from you
um you can also you can also like the
video to help the algorithm subscribe to
the channel if you haven't yet um share
the video if you think this conversation
about proteomics about big data um if
you think this has been helpful go ahead
and share this with other people that
you feel like this would resonate with
and check out the links in the bio below
to tianan's work
and if you want to get involved in their
international collaborations um if you
want to just reach out um to create
together with them feel free to um to
dive deeper into what they have
available online
and
yeah i think that's uh that's it
you have anything else you'd like to add
yeah this is very nice and uh i have a
team uh now they are not here later
after you send me this information uh we
will uh what i work with my team to
see how to collaborate with you in the
future will be in more extent
in the march meeting or
more events that we're going to
do so let's read your information and
then
let's think about
if we have more
opportunity to work together we can
schedule another meeting to discuss
about it
yeah sweet
sweet okay thanks cool yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna end our um just the recording
so just stay in the room for one more
minute with me okay
yeah okay thanks everyone thanks for
tuning in we love you see you soon